look let's be clear this was a very very
good result for the labor party because
what was clear was was a choice the
labor party has been putting forward a
positive plan for the future how we
stabilize and grow our economy so we
were putting a positive choice to the
electorate in Chester the government is
worn out tired has crashed the economy
and the verdict was very very clearly
given and I think that's a clear message
to the Prime Minister Rishi sunak but
people are fed up and they want to
change and there's this strong sense now
the government has run out of Road run
out of ideas hasn't got a mandate and
it's time for change
here's Scotland is still strong support
for the SMP although some positive
results in the clinicals for labor but
also suggestions and recent polls of a
lead in favor of Independence how do you
make gains here in Scotland well in
Scotland we've been improving our
position and the case I want to make in
Scotland is that we should have change
in Scotland but that should be change
within the United Kingdom a positive
case for Change and that also an
incoming labor government would clearly
have priorities which I think match
where most people are in Scotland which
is dealing with the cost of living
crisis dealing with our economy and
getting it growing making sure we've got
the right jobs in the right places and
that Scotland can Thrive so
um you know we're we're doing well in
Scotland we continue to build our case
but it's a very positive case for change
I'm not arguing for the status quo in
Scotland change over Scotland within
change within the United Kingdom
yes on a report I today suggest that
Paul told me costs its investment in the
North Sea as a result of the windfall
tax and are you concerned about this
policy harming North Sea jobs
the windfall tax is absolutely essential
because oil and gas companies have made
profits they didn't expect to make and
on the other hand people are really
struggling to pay their bills so it is
right that oil and gas companies pay
their fair share obviously what I want
to see is the push towards Renewables if
anything this is powerful evidence that
Labor's case that we need to rush
towards Renewables is the right case so
it gives us lower bills it gives us
independence from Putin so he can't put
his boots on our throat gives us the
jobs of the future and obviously it's
consistent with our climate obligations
so windfall tax is right but at the same
time alongside that as we've argued
we've got to push on towards Renewables
and what's your response to the Palace
racism right and will you be watching
the Harry and Megan documentary well
look there's no place for racism
anywhere and I think the royal family
will right to act